on prend la direction de moscou pour
retrouver notre correspondant antoine
cléroux antoine bonjour alors pour
moscou les états unis démantèle les
instruments de contrôle des armements
oui il ya comme un air de déjà vu il ya
un peu plus d'un an
les etats unis se retirer du traité sur
les forces nucléaires à portée
intermédiaire après avoir accusé la
russie de ne pas le respecter et la même
chose mais cette fois avec les traités
open sky ou ciel ouvert qui permettait
jusque là où pays signataires de ce sur
relay mutuellement afin par exemple de
surveiller des mouvements de troupes ou
le déploiement de nouveaux armements
les autorités russes estiment que rien
avoir à se reprocher et regrette le
manque de dialogue de la part de
washington garde et il n'y a aucune
violation de la part de la russie
toutes ces questions soulevées par les
états unis font l'objet de discussions
dans le cadre de la commission
consultative sur le traité ciel ouvert
d'ailleurs nous avons des réclamations
sérieuse quant à l exécution des
dispositions du traité de la part des
états unis eux mêmes mais ce sont des
questions techniques compliqués qui
doivent être résolus dans le cadre de
l'organe spécialement créé cette
commission qui évalue le fonctionnement
du contrat travail sur le développement
du mécanisme de sa mise en oeuvre et
examine également toutes les questions
qui peuvent se poser lors de vol
d'observation une décision unilatérale
de la part des états unis alors qu'il
s'agit d'un texte qui ne concerne pas
que la russie mais bien 35 clio total
effectifs dans six mois le retrait de
washington de ce document pourrait donc
avoir un impact sur le climat de
confiance et de sécurité entre tous les
pays signataires en particulier en
europe
les etats unis ont ajouté qu'il pourrait
reconsidérer leur position si la rue
s'ils venaient à remplir un
conditionnement toutes ses obligations
une proposition que moscou considère
être un ultimatum est pas une base de
discussion
écoutez
nous sommes ouverts au dialogue mais
uniquement un dialogue équitables visant
à prendre en compte les intérêts et
préoccupations de chacun mais washington
n'en n'a aucunement la tension préférant
se retirer du traité
c'est profondément regrettable car la
sécurité européenne s'en retrouve
gravement endommagés et justement les
alliés des etats unis ont rapidement
réagi désir soir bernard appelé
washington à reconsidérer sa position et
s'est déclaré être prêt à tout faire
pour préserver le traité
vous l'avez dit un communiqué des
ministères des affaires étrangères de
dix pays européens dont l'allemagne et
la france parue cet après-midi dit
regretter la décision des etats-unis
tout en partageant leurs préoccupations
vis-à-vis de la russie
le secrétaire général de l'otan après
une réunion d'urgence s'est également
dit attaché à ce texte
la russie qui est de son côté entend
bien continuer à respecter ce traité
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine clairon direct de
moscou